we've got to mention a straight out of
Compton congratulations Oscar nominated
Best Original Screenplay yes and
obviously because the Oscars and I got
mired in this in this controversy this
year so where do you stand on all of
that like will you go are you going I
never used to go anyways you're not
boycotting you can't boycott something
that you never went to anyway that's
kind of weird not you know it's a I look
at it as a you know like a horse race
you know I'm saying once your horse
loses the race you tear up your ticket
and gone and just back on now you know
because there's nothing really to put
that much energy into like that it's a
we don't do movies for the industry we
do movies for the fans for the people
and you know the industry you know if
they give you a trophy or not or patch
on the back or not it's nice but it's
not something that you should dwell on
you know we got accolades from all
levels you know from our core fans from
our curious fans from our fans or people
who you know didn't even think they
wanted to see that movie you know I
think a older generation got to
understanding on why we did that kind of
music and younger generation got a
history lesson and we got so much praise
for the movie and it's like how could
you be mad cuz one other academy or
guild or anybody didn't say is the
number in us like you know it's crying
about you know not having enough icing
on your cake and the mean is ridiculous
because you guys both seen the movie
Avenue yeah yeah yeah as I loved it
absolutely loved it and I think by the
way that that's about the same
ascription of the this whole process of
awards that I've ever heard I mean as a
way of treating it as a way thinking
about
they were like rap delish straight out
of Compton crazy my name ice cube from
the car
profanity you know I think let me
educate you something black people black
people notorious for picking things that
they saw one day and say that's my baby
name